quand on fait partie des anciens élèves
qui accusent les responsables de l'école
et de l'église mal toutes charges de
maltraitance criminels survenus entre
1995 et 2010 il rapporte avoir été
victime de maltraitance en 2004 alors
que quatre visiteurs replacer leur main
sur lui marc menant des prières pendant
près d'une heure et procédant à un
exorcisme pour le guérir de ce qu'il
disait être des démons homosexuels dans
une réputation écrite des allégations la
direction de l'école affirme ne jamais
avoir pratiqué l'exercice mais ne pas
être informé d'une telle pratique
l'établissement ajoute aussi avoir
procédé à des changements de personnel
et politique affirmant que les étudiants
lgbt qui plus ce sont les bienvenus
insultes châtiments physiques y
isolement cellulaire sont des exemples
de maltraitance rapportés par d'autres
ancien étudiant de l'école après douze
mois d'enquêté le service de police de
saskatoon a transféré le dossier au
procureur de la couronne en avril
dernier une décision concernant le
statut de la plainte collective est
attendue d'ici avril 2023 les victimes
rapportent que la majorité des
événements ont eu lieu après la décision
de la cour suprême du canada en 2004 qui
statuez qu'il est illégal imposé des
châtiments corporels à des enfants
les anciennes élèves évoquent aussi le
manuel disciplinaire de châu training
féminin vendus aux côtés de bible et de
palettes de bois dans la boutique de
cadeaux si bbc radio canada a obtenu une
copie du document de 85 pages qui
contient huit leçons indiquant de ne pas
laisser les larmes et les prières
atténuer la sévérité de la punition
cependant rien n'indique que le manuel
circulent encore ou que ces méthodes
sont toujours utilisés par le personnel
les anciennes élèves demandent au
gouvernement de la saskatchewan de
cesser le financement de l'école jusqu'à
ce que l'enquêté soit terminée
de son côté le ministère de l'éducation
de la saskatchewan a affirmé que les
écoles indépendantes était évalué trois
fois par année dont la dernière datait
du 8 juin le ministère a également
ajouté qu'aucune plainte n'avait été
reçue contre cette école ne piquait les
subventions accordées aux écoles
indépendantes qualifiés ont commencé en
2012 ici cassandra lebel radio canada
regina